hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar quality
control electronic records
for 21cfr part 11 data integrity
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by best
culture life sciences to learn more
visit beckman.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits i'd like to now present
today's speaker
tony harrison senior marketing manager
at best in culture life sciences
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen tony you may
now begin your presentation
welcome thank you for that introduction
hello and welcome everyone to this short
seminar today on
quality control compendium testing and
21 cfr part 11 data integrity
my name is tony harrison and i'm senior
manager for beckmann coulter
so today's presentation as i say it's
quite short it lasts
approximately 30 minutes and then of
course plus the question and answer
session at the end
now this talk takes a look at three
compendium
quality control test procedures and how
automation of those procedures can help
improve data
integrity by reducing the opportunities
for human error
the three quality control procedures
discussed in this presentation
form a common thread in the
biopharmaceutical manufacturing industry
and are water quality testing clean room
routine
environmental monitoring and final
injectable drug particulate
testing
so first let's take a look at quality
control testing
and how this can be open to human error
unfortunately resulting in data
integrity
issues
now in 2018 december of 2018 the fda
published their questions and answers
paper
relating to 21 cfr part 11 data
integrity
and they shared some fairly recent uh
sorry fairly worrying
observations they stated that in recent
years they'd increasingly observed cgmp
violations particularly involving data
integrity
during their inspections and they said
that these violations have led to
numerous regulatory
actions including warning letters import
alerts and consent degrees
and they go on to say that firms should
implement meaningful and effective
strategies to manage their data
integrity risks and what they're
suggesting is that you should make
processes more
robust
also in their 2018 guidance the fda
introduced the acronym for the first
time
alcoa and this is in response to a
what's what a good electronic record
should look like and
they say the the acronym stands for
attributable to the person taking the
sample
they suggest it should be legible and
therefore possible probably not
handwritten
sometimes handwriting can be difficult
to read
they should they say it should be made
contemporaneously which means
at the time of the test so the
electronic record should be made
at the time of the test and rather than
later and i they're referring there
really
to the common practice of taking paper
printouts from test machines
and then manually typing that
information in to create the electronic
record at a later time
and they're saying that's not good
practice and they also say of course the
electronic record
should be the original one and the data
it contains
should be accurate and it's that last
accurate a for accurate that i'm going
to
focus on today
now in a typical manual sampling
and data quality control uh situation
there's many
manuals as steps in the sop and first
the technician first of all of course
technician has to make sure
they're using the correct version of the
sop
and then they have to manually configure
the instrument to sample for the correct
volume and the correct number of samples
according to the sop for each different
test
next they print the sample results out
and hand write the comments onto the
printer
printout and sign it with their name to
make it attributable
and then at the end of each day they
manually type the results
in to create the electronic record from
all these pieces of paper they've
created
and finally the electronic record has to
be reviewed by the supervisor
a to ensure that all the samples are
being taken correctly and b
that the data in the electronic record
matches the paper printouts
now as you can see this is a very manual
process
and with thousands of samples pieces of
paper and manual data transcriptions
every month
the opportunity for human error to creep
in and impact the integrity of the data
or the accuracy of the data very high
indeed
so i wanted to share with you a study
which is done by the industrial
biodevelopment
laboratory and they showed in a test
between
16 experienced qc technicians performing
the same
manual sop standard operating procedure
a variability of up to 20 between the
results
now you could argue that the manual sop
could be improved and the technicians
retrained
but such variability and results does
suggest that manual processes
are arguably not robust enough to
deliver the required
levels of quality control
now whilst the technical specifications
of similar instrumentation may appear
equivalent when looking to improve
quality control
the qc team should really be looking at
the level of automation that the
instrument offers
to make qc testing more robust and
repeatable
for example a common source of errors in
qc testing is sample preparation so
any instrument that alternates this
process can enhance the reproducibility
and the robustness of a qc test
so let's take a look at our first
quality control test
the quality control testing for purified
water
and water for injection and in fact
in this talk here i'll talk about how we
can use online instrumentation that
automate this testing
and use that data from them to help
release batch
files
now total organic carbon or toc and
conductivity are two
of the four critical water quality
attributes defined for water injection
and purified water
in the united states pharmacopoeia now
online analyzers such as the pat 700
from batman culture
can be validated to comply fully with
both of these
key quality attributes according to the
pharmacopeel
requirements
the pharmacopoeia is asked that toc is
measured by first measuring the
inorganic material present in the sample
total inorganic carbon they call this or
tic
and the pharmacopoeia's guide us that
tic's mainly dissolved carbon dioxide in
purified water and water injection
the pharmacopoeia is then asked that the
organic material present in the sample
is now
completely oxidized to release the
organic carbon in the form of carbon
dioxide
the carbon dioxide from the organic or
sorry oxidized organic material
and the inorganic carbon dioxide now add
together to represent the total carbon
present in the water or tc
and then the pharmacopoeia is asked that
we subtract the tic
from the tc to calculate the total
organic carbon or toc now this is a
graphical representation of the
oxidization process initially the
conductivity of the water sample is
measured to establish the amount of tic
present in the sample which as i said is
made up of carbon dioxide dissolved in
the water
then an ultraviolet lamp is used to
oxidize all the organic material in the
sample to carbon dioxide
and when there's no further changes in
the conductivity we know we've completed
that
oxidation and the analyzer measures the
new conductivity value which is the
total carbon or tc
and then it subtracts the initial
conductivity measurement the tic from
the tc
and the difference in this is directly
proportional to the toc
or in the water sample itself
now traditionally data from online toc
analyzers is fed straight to the site's
supervisory control
or data acquisition system or
distributed control systems scada or dcs
and making access to this data for qc
team difficult
however the p8700 can be configured to
automatically
send pdf electronic records every day
over the ethernet for review and batch
release
and this satisfies the fda's alcoa
requirement for electronic records to be
accurate
legible contemporaneously created
original
and attributable
now unlike laboratory waters quality
testing
instruments which utilize reagents and
require manual configuration for each
sample and frequent
sometimes daily calibration the online
pat 700 from beckmann culture
requires no reagents it automates the
test protocol and only requires
calibration every 12 months
calibration and system suitability
testing sops are automated
requiring no manual data entry and pass
fail reports are automatically generated
from the instrument
eliminating manual calculations
calibration standards once loaded into
the p8700
upload their certified value lot number
and expiry date to the p8700
using radio frequency identification
electronic chips are located on the
calibration bottles
and these are read by the p8700 thus
avoiding manual data entry
okay so let's move on to look what can
be done to automate
routine clean room environmental
monitoring
programs
now there are this of course falls onto
the gmps and there are two main
flavors of the gmps this is the american
north american
cgmp and the european and world health
gmp
annex one which is the same document so
everywhere in the world follows the
european annex one apart from north
america with the cgmp document
now both these gmp documents however
call up the the iso standard iso one
four six
forty four part one and for the
methodology of clean room classification
so let's take a look at the gmp
regulations controlling the
contamination
levels in these clean rooms now this is
the current table
for the air particle contamination
levels in the european gmp
annex one and as i said it's the same in
the guys with steroid manufacturing from
the world
health organization now i say the
current table because currently the
annex one is under review
however that's been happening over a
period of many years
and the last version uh of the
annex proposed new annex i saw was
version 12. so
i'm not holding my breath for the next
one but it will get revised
and you can see there's four grades here
of clean room
from the very cleanest grade a to the
dirtiest grade d
and you can see that the european gmp
calls for two particle
sizes to be measured both 0.5 and 5
microns now this is the same the world
over because the world health
organization follows the same
and the only difference is the north
american cgmp
which only calls for 0.5 micron
particles to be measured and reported
all particle counts are reported in
particles per
cubic meter for both gmps and this
itself can present an error a potential
error sorry an
area of potential error because in order
to reduce the amount of time
taking typically in routine
environmental
monitoring programs the sample taken at
each location is often just
one minute sample now with a one cubic
foot per minute
particle counter that means that the
sample volume taken is just one cubic
foot of air
and now there are approximately 35.2
cubic feet of air in one cubic meter
so used users must multiply the counts
results by 35.2 to get the counts per
meter
so you can see the opportunity for error
there now it is true
that most particle counters can be
programmed to automatically make this
calculation
for the user but it's another
configuration step to remember to do to
ensure the results are reported
correctly and i have seen people
not doing that and just writing down the
counts per cubic foot
now as i mentioned the north american
fda cgmp document does differ to the
european and world health organization
guidance
in the only mentions one particle size
the 0.5 micron particles
however of course drug manufacturers
based in north america wanting to sell
their products
outside of north america will have to
count both .5 and 5
microns as they have to be in compliance
with the standards of the industry
and the country to which they want to
export
now as i mentioned a couple of moments
ago both the european
gmp and the north american gmp tell the
reader to refer to the classification
procedures laid down in the iso standard
1 4
6 4 part 1 for classification
now this in itself is not a gmp document
and it's designed to give guidance
rather than mandate
but the fact that it's referenced by the
gmps gives it the same status as a gmp
document
for those manufacturers regulated by gmp
now it has a wide range of clean room
classes as you can see from one
to nine and it covers again a wide range
of particle sizes from 0.5 microns up to
5 microns
and then it defines in the table the
number of particles
for each class you'll notice this is the
2015
version of the iso standard here and for
those of you
with sharp eyes will notice this at iso
class 5
um for 5 microns there's no number in
the table anymore that was removed
in the 2015 version however
um if you're complying to the european
gmp or world health organization
that five micron particles is still in
those regulations so
even though it's gone from the um the
146 44 document
you still have to measure those if
you're complying with european or world
health organization rules
so the idea with the iso standard is the
user must decide
what particle sizes they're interested
in and how clean the clean room must be
and then they choose a subset of the
clean room classes and particle size
from the iso table
now gmp the european version has decided
that particle sizes are interest of 0.5
and 5 microns and you can see from grade
b at rest if we go to the grade b
table here 0.5 and 5
and the number of particles in the table
there are the same
as iso class 5. so you can see how gmp
has taken a subset of the iso
to make the the gmp regulations
and don't forget if you're following
european gmp
or you are following world health
organization
it is 0.5 and 5 microns still
now discussions i've had as i travel the
world and speak to
users of clean rooms in the gmp
environment
is that and there's an increasing trend
where the burden of carrying out these
routine environmental monitoring
testing particularly air particle
counting is moving away from the qc
microbiology team and over to the
production staff for two reasons firstly
the microbiology staff are
very overqualified shall we say to carry
out such simple routine tasks
and the second point is it reduces the
number of people in the clean rooms
thus hopefully reducing the potential
for product contamination
however the downside is the production
team do not
of course have the same high level of
knowledge about microbial and routine
environmental monitoring
and this creates challenges in itself
now routine environmental monitoring is
arguably one of the most manual
and complex processes that we have to do
it involves the collection of thousands
of samples each month
using portable air particle counters
and typically there are many manual sop
steps to follow it in the routine
environmental monitoring program
first of course the technician has to
make sure they're using the correct
version of the paper
sop then they have to follow the uh
something map in the sop and go to every
sample location
then they have to manually type the
location name into the counter via the
on-screen keyboard
and next they have to configure the
counter to sample for the correct amount
of time
correct volume and the number of samples
according to their own sop for each
location
next they print the sample results out
from the counter and handwrite any
comments onto the printout
and then sign it with their name and at
the end of every day they photocopy all
these printouts
and then they manually transcribe the
results from every piece of paper
to create an electronic record then
finally at the end of the day the
electronic record is reviewed by the
supervisor to try and ensure that all
the samples have been taken correctly
and the data in the electronic record
actually matches that of the paper
printouts so
as you can see this is a horrible manual
process and with thousands of samples
pieces of paper manual data
transcriptions every month
the opportunity for human error to creep
in and impact the integrity of the data
is very high
so with the new uh met one thirty four
hundred plus particle counter from
uh beckman cult we've tried to address
these issues with the clarity software
which runs inside the counter itself
first of all improves the accuracy
because you it allows you to upload your
own
sampling map from your routine
environmental monitoring
sop into the counter creating an
interactive version of that sampling map
on the screen of the counter itself
now clarity software includes as i said
the interactive sampling map on the
counter screen
the electronic records are created
contemporaneously and can be exported
via
built-in wi-fi or wired ethernet and
this is standard
it exports these in secure pdf they're
password protected pdf
or you can get it in excel if you want
to trend them
and there's a tab separated variable
format for lims integration
it uses microsoft active directory for
username and password control so it's
very secure
and the exporting the data exporting
function is
ldap which is the currently regarded as
the most secure way of doing this
this time sop version control is done in
the counter itself
and the name of the sop that's been used
on the day
plus the version number appears inside
the electronic record so you have high
traceability
now the counter can work with a usb
barcode reader barcode scanner sorry and
it can scan the
microbial plates used at each location
so they then appear in the
um electronic record as well so that way
you're tying
the settle plate and the active air
plates that you use at each location in
the clean room
to a date and a time so this gives
traceability for those plates
so you can see in the electronic record
you have the plate ids you have the name
of the user
and you have the particle count results
all in one electronic record
so finally let's take a look at the
requirements for particulate testing
in parental drug solutions and see how
these tests themselves can be made
more robust now
the global harmonic appears are
harmonized and the fact that they all
recommend
a primary method for subvisible
particulates
counting in parenteral to be light
obscuration or
sometimes the terms light blocking and
this is the preferred method as i said
for subvisible particle testing
they go on to say that if it's not
possible to use light obscuration for
some
reason for instance if the solution is
too viscous or too dark
then you can use a secondary method
which is the optical
microscope however there's good reason
why light
observation is the preferred preferred
method
and of course the reason for that is
that the contaminating particles we find
in parenterals are not con conveniently
circular
which would allow ease so it would allow
easier and more reproducible counting
and sizing
instead the counting particles using a
microscope is very subjective
and there's there are several methods
aimed at standardizing the sizing of
irregular sayings particles but
unfortunately there's not just one
method
and the methods available include
deciding which is the largest dimension
and measuring that or the alternative
methods of martin's diameter and ferrets
diameter
and the problem is they are not only
subjective but each method gives a
different result
now light observation on the other hand
use the laser light to illuminate a
measurement window
the intensity of the light is measured
by a sensor and turned into an
electrical signal
the counter is calibrated by passing
various sizes of spherical beads through
the counter
partially blocking the laser light and
the resultant change in the electrical
signal can now be said to be equivalent
to each particle's size
and now the sample under test is passed
through the con
through and the contaminating particles
will cause a reduction in the laser
light reaching the sensor
they'll block it or obscure it
and the resultant change in the electric
electrical signal
signal is then compared to those of the
calibrating particles and an equivalent
spherical diameter
can be assigned to the particle now this
method is far more repeatable and it's
non-subjective and that's why they use
light obscuration or recommend that you
should
so let's take a look at the compendium
test methods for subvisible particle
counting
we'll start with usp 788 and ep
2.9.9
the pharma compares here are harmonized
on the required compendium method
and of course it's not possible to test
all the valves in a production batch
because the valves have to be opened to
be tested
so pharmacobears ask as a minimum sample
from each production batch of 10 vials
be pooled
and analyzed however they go on to say
that
that four samples of five mil each are
taken from the pooled sample
asking that the first sample results are
discarded to prevent carryover from the
previous test
and that the subsequent three sample
results are averaged
now to accomplish this test the farmwick
appears required that the total pooled
volume
of these vials must be at least 25
milliliters
as a minimum so in many cases more than
10 valves are required to achieve this
minimum pulled volume
depending on the dosal dosage volume in
each of those vials
as i mentioned the pharmacopoeias are
harmonized on this testing
and the pass fail control sorry pascal
criteria for small volume and parentals
of less than 100 ml
dosage form is based on the maximum
number of particles at 10 microns and
larger
and 25 microns and larger
for large volume parenteral solutions
larger than 100 mils
the particle sizes are the same 10 and
25 microns
but the difference is the number of
particles are expressed
as particles per container for the small
volume parenterals
and as counts per milliliter for the
large
volume parenterals so the way the counts
are expressed is different
so now let's take a look at the
relatively new united states chapter 787
now this is designed specifically to
provide a method a conventional method
for testing
subvisible particulate contamination in
therapeutic proteins such as vaccines
and any large molecule biologic drug
now the pass fail criteria for for the
787
is the same as it is for 788 and the
difference actually lies
in the required compendium test method
unlike 788 787 allows the testing to be
carried out on just
one single vial and calls for a minimum
sample
volume of just 0.2 milliliters now if
you remember
they wanted four lots of five
milliliters or 788 so this is quite
radically different
now applying this test method using
particle counters can prove
challenging as the target for the
sampler is much smaller because there's
not lots of
um vials are pulled into a beaker it's
just a single
um vial and it often has a small conical
base which means it won't stand upright
and you have to have it exactly in the
right place so the sampler
will take the sampler so most particle
counters of course
have a relatively large tear volume
certainly large when compared to 0.2
milliliters
or dead volume sometimes called and this
is the volume that must be pulled into
the counter
before the sample reaches the sensor and
can be counted now
the hiac 9703 sampler can be optimized
for this compendium test by using
the optional small vial clamp holds the
vial upright
and in exactly the right location for
the sampling arm to take the sample
and we have a sampling probe with a very
small tear volume
it's only got 0.091
milliliters tear volume so we can
optimize this test for
for biologics testing
now as i mentioned although largely
harmonized the requirements before
parental drug
particulate testing do vary and
particularly from product to product the
volume of the sample to be analyzed and
the format the results are reported
varies from product to product as i said
in the table so the sampling
requirements for small volume
therapeutic proteins such as vaccines
is different very different to that of a
large volume parental such as
an intravenous drip bag now results must
be calculated and expressed in the
correct format
eg for small volume parentals is counts
per container
for large parenterals like drip bags is
counts per milliliter
so the way the results are expressed
depends on the type
of product you're testing so partial
counters
just do a measurement and deliver
particle counts per milliliter
that leaves the operator then to
calculate the number of particles per
container
or per milliliter and of course that
manual calculation
and interpretation of the results can
invite opportunities for human error
to creep in
so the compendium testing for
subphysical particles can present
opportunities for human error as i
mentioned and subsequent data integrity
challenges so this i'm showing on the
screen here is a fictitious example
but it serves to show what can happen
these are two fictitious drug products
in the same size enclosure they're both
in five mil
vials a product a has a patient dosage
volume of just
one milliliter now product b however has
a patient dosage volume of 1.5
milliliter
now running the test for both product
types on a standard particle counter
delivers the same concentration of
particles at 25 microns
of 500 particles per milliliter for both
these
now is this a pass or a fail for these
two products
now with product a there's just one mil
in the vial so with 500 milliliters of
uh sorry 500 particles per mil the
container itself
only contains 500 particles at 25
microns
and this is a pass when you compare it
to the maximum allowed
per container of 600 in the compendium
test
however product b has exactly the same
number of particles per milliliter
but because the patient dose is 1.5
milliliter
this container now has 750 particles
per container in it which is a fail when
compared to the compendium list
sorry compared to your limits of 600
particles per container
so you can see do the tests on two
different products and you get
one passes the other one fails the test
results are exactly the same so
it's it can be very complicated and
messy
so whilst you can use a general purpose
liquid particle counter
for testing particles and parenteral
products what we've done in with the
hayak
particle counters from beckmann culture
is you optimize them for this
application
due to the complexity in the testing and
the opportunity for human error
so the various compendium tests all
built into the hiax software
and the hack will automatically
calculate a pass fail results based on
which
whichever compend your test the user is
using
as qc 10 sorry qc10 teams tend to refer
to their product
by the brand name describing to describe
the product
um the optional procedure builder module
for the hayek
software allows the user to name the
compendium test by their product names
so you have a list of the product names
instead of the list of the compendium
test and
all the user now does is simply selects
the required tests for each sample
by suggesting the product besides
selecting the product by name
from a drop down menu the count then
automatically applies the correct
compendium test
each product and there's no manual
calculations as the correct compendium
pass fail criteria
for each product are applied and a
report is
automatically generated
so i'm coming to the end of my
presentation now i'd like to summarize
the key points
in our industry it's very common that we
typically focus on retraining when
mistakes uh or data integrity issues
happen
however the underlying issue we're
facing really is that retraining may not
be the best solution
manual sops are just not robust enough
to prevent future recurrence of data
errors and emissions
so you see instrumentation that automate
the quality control sop
can potentially both reduce the impact
of human error on the data integrity
but also bring welcome cost savings by
reducing the time
technicians need to devote to manually
configuring the insurance
and carrying out multiple pass fail
calculations
so thank you for your time today i
appreciate you joining me and listening
so
um let's this is the end of the
presentation so let's take a look at
any questions that have been posted
during the session
thank you for your more informative
presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
so tony your first question says
thank you for your presentation please
can you tell me how the met one thirty
four hundred
ensures that the technician is using the
correct version
of the routine environmental monitoring
sop
great thank you very much for your
question and thanks for attending today
so the sop version control is actually
done inside the particle counter itself
by the manager or the administrator
and once they've set it up and they're
happy they've configured it in the
counter
according to their sop correctly they
release the sop for use
on the counter using their electronic
signature
and now the sop appears on the
environmental monitoring technician
screen
ready for use and also the sop name and
the version number that was used at the
time
of the routine environmental monitoring
is actually included in the electronic
records generated by the counter
so it's very easy to check which sop was
used
thank you all right your next question
how does the pat 700 ensure the
integrity
of the pdf electronic records that it
generates
thank you it's good question in fact in
the 21cfr part 11 guidance from the
fda pdf is one of the recommended file
types and they suggest that because you
can read pdf on many different platforms
android
uh microsoft etc etc so the
idea is you should be able to read that
record well into the future
and the way we uh ensure the integrity
of these pdfs is
that the pat applies a randomly
generated password to each pdf which
secures them and prevents them from
being changed
okay and let's go ahead and wrap up with
this last question
how do i know if the technician used the
correct companion
method on the hayak 9703
so in fact the compendium test method
control again is done via the software
in the counter
and the compendium test method and its
version number are included in the
electronic pass fail report generated by
the hayak
just as we saw with the met one for for
routine environmental monitoring
now additionally the technician chooses
the appropriate test from a drop-down
list
in this case just using their own
product names
so they don't even really need to know
which compendium test to use with which
product they simply look up the product
name in the drop-down list
select it and the hayak automatically
applies the correct compendium test
method
according to their product
thank you tony and do you have any final
comments for our audience before we go
today
no no i thank you i just wanted to say
thanks again for attending and i hope it
was informative and useful
well thank you again tony for your time
today and your research
we would also like to thank lombards and
our sponsor beckman culture life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions a
reminder
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
and labverts will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we invite you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye